hi everyone it's Jerry I'm going to hop
into this hourly rapid Arena and just
get three games in it
seems late
joining 54 minutes to go this was an
hour 57 minute event 10 plus 0 time
control been a while since I posted a
rapid video
let's see who we get in round one 276
are in
here okay here we
go game
one I'm assuming it'll be three games
maybe
four
thinker this is so
C3 Sicilian okay I've been experimenting
with
this this move meeting E5 with Knight
back
okay I have just been
juked
expecting this one or the pawn to
eventually go to
D4 they've made a
u-turn no D4
could still play it with
[Music]
preparation but it's costing a Tempo
now okay this
is feels like a system
player he going for some familiar
structure
um yeah it can't be the best
objectively so how to approach this no
peace development so far by
white it makes sense to put this guy on
D5 there's
no worry of this Advance all
right
and initially I was thinking take with
the queen but or take with the Knight
but I think taking with the queen is
best this is
a a point to put some pressure on now
Bishop F5 Rook
d8 where am I going with this
Pawn I don't know let me let me still go
here first I'm pretty pretty sure I know
where this light Square Bishop wants to
be so let's get him there all
right and I'm going to go straight in
for this so I'm still three moves out
from Castle a little bit iffy on if this
is the best move here but white has
wasted some moves H3 doesn't really
feel
productive more long term it's useful
for the flight square but there's more
important stuff happening right now in
the
center
okay so I
see trying to win a pawn in the end I'll
have a rook here there's Bishop E3 get
the pawn
back feel very weird to have to go here
to defend running into more
moves or a move like Knight C3 with
Tempo
um I could still play it
where just continue to
develop e E6 should be perfectly healthy
I don't know if I'm
really getting anywhere with captures
yeah let's let's bring it to point where
I'm two steps away from
castles I don't want to be too quick to
open up the C3 Square for the Knight
okay this is a another bishop move
Knight is in a
pin this Knight is also in a pin
get
G2 I'm just seeing that if I take
here I'm on the
bishop
so I think I'm going to do
that why
not took a pawn generated a threat a new
square has opened up for the bishop and
they're missing that I'm on this
guy
yeah guess they had a take here they
missed the lateral movement
there
resigner or not a resigner okay it's
maybe looking more like four
games will be in
there maybe four will
count and there'll be a fifth play but
it won't
count 280 5 in here
now 21 points and all out berserk yeah
I'm not really ever a fan of berserking
these rapid
Arenas just looking to play some quality
games all
right let's go
E4 and let's go for a scotch let's see
they going to play Knight
C6 filor
Petro something else
filor let's go D4 we go with the queen
pin the
KN place an emphasis on rapid peace
play this already half open
position this is a moment to
pause yeah why actually I was playing
those last few moves as if it was Blitz
forgetting here rapid time
control so what I'm what I'm considering
here is whether or not to insert C4
before Knight
C3 this does increase my control over
D5 um I think I like
that yeah let's go C4 and then Knight
C3 not sure where I want a
castle with this half openen
defile queenside Castle is a bit more
appealing but we'll see so maybe since
I'm up in the air
some with where to
Castle uh I should be thinking more
about developing my dark Square Bishop
first not
sure at the same time I don't know if
it's really A wise choice to go
queenside Castle now that I have my Pawn
on
C4 it's one less Pawn Defender for my
king this is the most
solid also I just don't feel like I know
just yet where my dark Square Bishop
belongs yeah let's just go kingside
castles this one this one flight
Square yeah maybe the flight
square if I if I try Bishop F4 I think
this one is
available
I don't want to allow Bishop for Knight
exchange I don't want to have two
Knights versus two Bishops
position so I guess I'll
insert well and here's another thing I
could actually consider improving my
knight yeah let me let me reconsider
here maybe withdrawing my
queen it's not really doing a whole lot
in the center there's then Knight D4
which which also helps prevent uh this
F5
Advance which is the only Pawn break
really for
black yeah I'm going to go with this one
another detail I guess is
that if black tries to put pressure on
e4 I don't have to continually devote
pieces to defending E4 once my knight is
on D4 I could consider F3 and it ties in
perfectly with my dark Square Bishop so
I guess swing the back completely around
on this
idea um I don't know that it's necessary
for this bishop to fall back maybe it
is yeah because the the Knight on F5 is
a pretty irritating piece and you start
to think about
sacrifices Knight F5 Bishop takes Queen
G3
mate yeah that's probably the most
solid maybe this is the location for my
Bishop at the end of the day just one
step um I'll go with that and go with
this one just one step why am I going
one
step feel like it's a bit more
vulnerable on well not
vulnerable well yeah on E3 it's
vulnerable to maybe Knight G4 F4 Knight
H5 also once The Rook is here okay
that's a really big
move the bishop stays out of the way of
the Rooks if I want to put them on these
adjacent
files so this square right
now is
huge
so I could get there in a few moves and
there's not really anything black can do
to stop it going forward don't really
want to end up with double def
pawns maybe in a a situation where I
could see this Pawn acting as a
battering ram but I don't see pushing
through with F6
so let's not take on a double Dev Pawn
[Music]
structure so what I want exactly these
guys to be exchanged these guys to be
exchanged and drop a knight here and it
stays there
forever connection
issue okay
well let's go here right
now or a position where it's dark Square
Bishop battle specific with the minor
pieces that's cool
too it's coming together now I have uh
because of this
move I kind of know where my pieces
belong a bit more so I still have this
move this is is
covered these squares are both
holes so I yeah I might have been just
too lazy there with Rook D1 maybe as
soon as the bishop left this I should
have played Knight here cuz I would be
threatening this and then
this could still be an
idea um yeah let me let me still go here
threatening a crushing Bishop takes H6
Pawn takes check Knight Blocks made
eventually on G7 although wait a second
if the bishop backs off it's covering
those squares
okay maybe at the end of the day that
wasn't the
best all right before I make this
committ move F3 let's just defend
they're having connection issue very
Blinky Rook F to
E1 I'd prefer not to play
F3 I think in the end I'll I'll
eventually be playing
that Bishop here if I take I'm probably
asking for some problems after the light
Square Bishop moves I'm in a
pin it's maybe still possible I have
Bishop F4 defending defending we'll
see all right another connection
problem Rook there to
defend
okay man let's just put the pawn on here
I've given up on any thought of maybe a
sacrifice in the queen getting to G3
it's just a nice and solid in the
center make sure no accident happens on
e4 this I think is meant with this
one maybe I could flicking another pawn
move to be careful creating a hole on G3
but
H3 Bishop F3 my Bishop is around to
watch over that weakness Target a
weakness two two Nice Notes
there attack and
defense what I don't want to have happen
structure-wise
is a piece drop in here and I don't want
have to recapture with a
pawn cuz then this guy they never have
to worry about this Pawn
I want this to always be backward
targetable not easy to extract this
Knight G6 hangs F uh
H6 this this this this my Bishop's
unprotected on H6 but there's no
wonderful followup to take advantage of
that
maybe in some positions if this bishop
was here and pawn was here there's some
sacrifice there followed up with Queen
H4 to take advantage of the unprotected
Bishop but not
here
okay let's sneak this one in I got my
flight square and maybe I get this
maneuver in
there this I'm fine with Bish uh Knight
H5 five then just fall back Let's do
let's do
this so let's let's count here let's go
back to basics just counting pieces I
got four on this they have
three am I not ready to now win a
pawn really well
coordinated okay running in Reverse so
they've these squares have just lit up
in my
mind this is a possibility
maybe maybe I go with this one yeah let
me let me emphasize my control over
these light squares this one
here I am kind of thinking about in
playing A4 is in fact one day
maybe uh taking with the pawn and having
a five versus four uh on the king side
and Center for me tipping in my favor
and black will have this three versus
two where this two restricts these three
really
well not so easy it's like an I
considered an unhealthy majority this
really seems like it's asking for
trouble so if I play
here setting up a discovered
check so what's the plan this G6 I could
take I'm also on this for how many moves
a lot of
moves E5 G6 Knight takes Rook here is
that the
idea really don't know how that that's
playing
out um it feels like it's the right way
to approach this but but I'm a bit
concerned
about this and Rook
D7
H I'm I'm not going to go for that just
yet go with this
one and if this I'm going to take
towards the center I'm going to go for
that idea with the structural change my
KN could also make use of the C4 Square
which should be excellent even on the
clock doesn't seem like they have a
connection issue anymore not seeing them
blinking
really in the tank
here oh here's another detail where
where exactly is The Rook going Bishop
takes Pawn takes has to go over
here
okay that's a hole
now just come
back ton of different ways to recap sure
on D5 I still think I'm going with the
pawn
okay let's just come all the way
back this crossed my mind as well so I
could play Bishop
G3 just extract the queen that was maybe
best yeah I what I was what I was
thinking is that oh if this then I have
to recapture with my knight to make sure
my Bishop is is still
defended but I I would have had a an in
between move King H2 Bishop takes Knight
Bishop G3 first and then I
could oh maybe there's Bishop takes Pawn
hitting my queen yeah safe and
sound less calculation involved nice and
cozy these guys are on their back foot
the Knight
especially this Rook is a bit
clumsy my Pawn is now in a
pin
all
right let's just make a a quick move I'm
not exactly sure what I should do just
yet this was appealing driving the pond
down
okay
let's try
this on The Rook if Rook here I have
this one and they have to give up the
light Square Bishop otherwise I win the
exchange not not exactly sure what my
followup is if the Rook goes here okay
this one I am
sure the light Square
bishop or The
Rook also go with this one yeah this is
maybe good too
get the Queens off or win
material back on the rook and now I
should find it much easier to put
everything on this point I think I'm
just winning this
Pawn this this here might want to be a
little bit careful about how I stack the
Rooks if I go with this this guy's
unprotected and maybe allows
F5 so a safer approach is this one
first Bishop G5
let's let's improve the king first of
all yeah I definitely want to go here if
Bishop there putting pressure here also
stopping Bishop
D4 and I'm on this how many times
now
three King F1 Rook D3 Rook
D1 put my full weight on
D6 Knight C7 take there might be a
bishop check okay I could
take it might as well they have to take
with the
rook and before improving my king I
don't want to allow this guy to clamp
down on my king side
structure want to still factor in
positional Pawn play before peace
Improvement
there okay now I'm going to step closer
with my king this is secure and I'm
ready to finally
double Night
Exchange okay um I guess I'm going to go
For The Night
Exchange and get the rook and pawn
ending in the end pivot on the furthest
Advanced
Square now I'm threatening this
defending really well okay now they've
given me a moment to get this break
in F6 was necessary I
believe taking advantage of
this weak Pawn
finally it's been many moves ago when C5
was played and this weakness on D6 and
D5 were
created take with one Rook or no let's
let's not
allow both or a pair of Rooks to be
exchang just yet I like this guy
here I want to make use of it increasing
the pressure on H5 allows a an outside
past
Pawn so if we get into a king and pawn
ending okay the time is a big problem
here
but if I end up with the GH versus FG
I'm going to have an outside pass
Pawn
okay King and pawn ending yeah Inc
coming we'll take here
first if they take here I exchange and
then put the other Rook
here maybe i' play
here yeah I think this is correct say
you take me I want this
Pawn
take now this
is is probably a move
but okay they don't have any time I'm
just just wondering if this is a one
king and pawn
ending now push here they're in
time I don't know any move is going to
win on the clock but I'm just wondering
what's best in the end
here
H this this here here King
up I'm not sure if it's a one king and
pawn ending I'm actually just hair
curious if the king and pwn ending would
have been
one yeah cuz these these two pawns do
end up restricting these
three okay I wasn't really sure the
details
exactly one more game will count for
sure let's see who we get 333 in
here I got the the question mark next to
my
rating been a bit since I played
rapid all right there we
go bit of a
weight all right let's still go with the
Sicilian trying to get Scholars
mate all
right I'm looking forward to this move
with
tempo
or maybe even this move let's see how
they react to that if if A4 yeah I'm
almost certain this Knight definitely
belongs here when I see A4 and it's not
only about this control over D4 but the
B4
square is nice so I believe now I'm able
to get this move in they want to stop it
they go here
but in a way this is their better Bishop
even though there aren't fixed pawns
they do
have primary construction is on light in
the
center okay so am I really actually mean
am I gaining a whole lot with this
advance I guess
I guess I
am can't be bad got D5 in with Tempo so
here's another detail
do I want to allow Bishop here I'm going
to end up with some pressure on D5 if
Bishop G5 is
allowed I think it's important
to make sure Bishop G5 is not
available
okay and if I go here I hang a
pawn
maybe
here so that I could play Bishop here
next what I'm trying to do long term is
play against this this
bishop what I mean by that is once I
have these Rooks connected I want to I
want to go for I want to get a pawn Trio
and then C4 and that that triangle
construction squashes a minor piece
piece so
wonder I mean this is
simple but maybe this guy goes here so
that I could play here next I'm
expecting the bishop to be deployed to
F4
because well where
else
um yeah let's go here if I go to this
square and there's Queen E2
and I don't know maybe that's a bit
irritating so I could think a bit more
about this
move yeah why
not stopping a knight move into E5 this
is an intersection Square I got two on
it so I'm guessing castles is the way
get out of the pin this is now full
strength fully defended to Defender
here for a moment there just one
Defender okay that's a very slow move
also my Bishop on E6 I'm now saying that
I
could play this move C4 an
idea C4 takes
takes or do I still shoot for this
this one and then
here and are they going for some
sacrifice
there
possibly this here I always just watch
out for that Bishop there Queen
c yeah
but maybe maybe I deploy the queen
first yeah let's go here connect it's
not just about connecting Rooks but
aimed at
stopping well if Queen C1 I could play
here defend this pawn and I'm also
stopping Bishops Bishop to
F4 so I'm just going to negate the only
idea behind Queen C1 as far as I can
tell all of our Knights are
on good squares mine are more stable
white always has to watch out for this
idea so this
guy always has to know where his next
home is going to be I think it has a
perfectly fine home if I am ever playing
this night
night4 but then we're we're
trading okay so they're going in for
that right away so I was thinking this
and then here but now that the Knight is
not supporting that square feel like I I
could get this in right now but also I
think think maybe playing C4
[Music]
here okay they're I mean they're angling
for this
Square yeah I'm going to I'm going to go
in for this
one I'm giving up a really big
Square
okay I have to find a new home soon so
I'm almost there okay so here we are I
do have two pawns that are doing a good
job of restricting this light Square
Bishop not sure exactly where I should
go with my Bishop if a knight goes to
one of these
two okay and that's a
really interesting move breaking down my
light
squares okay got to go much faster what
am I
doing if I put some pressure on this guy
what's happening I got to go quicker
let's try
this ready
to crush the kingside structure
now this was maybe the wrong wrong
Square to go to actually because what's
no longer an idea is to meet this
capture with a
B4 because it's on my Bishop so this
could be some Pawn sacrifice idea just
to still work against the
bishop so if the Knight simply moves
somewhere actually where does the knight
move first of all it doesn't have H2 oh
allowing Bishop takes Knight that's
super
surprising okay I think yeah destroying
the king side is okay I see a
win I see a
win yeah we got let me just make sure
this bishop takes loses the Knight the
only other move is Bishop here but then
I have B4 and the bishop is forever
caged
if I establish pawns on C3 and B4 this
guy's Dead Forever I don't see how
they're tracking these two pawns down
feel like they're conveniently
defended there's other appealing moves
as well this is now
unprotected F3 so Knight here but I
think more to the
point is just this move
here
C3
no time to maybe capture
here I'm on the I'm on the bishop and
then the queen The
Rook so Bishop there and just B4 and say
what is this guy doing
ever I think that's the way I got this
guy under control with my pawn and my
knight these two control the
night they might
resign
might balance material position but this
is an
imaginary
piece doesn't really doesn't really
exist
here
Pawn takes away some squares from many
pieces Bishop
Queen
okay maybe sneak in one more
move A5
or is that even
necessary
not really necessary let's just move
faster Knight here I could take and give
a check and win The
Rook all right let's get this one
in I don't care if the Knight ends up
here
anyhow night take take Knight here drift
Over Fork these U weak squares H4 and
F4 Knight would be fantastic on
G6 any exchange should be excellent for
me I have to watch out in some cases if
we get into an
ending um if we get into an ending that
this bishop doesn't go into Pac-Man
mode but I do have this one covered
there really isn't going to be any
accident happening here as far as I
could
tell they're trying for
that it's like the only
point I could cover
it Knight to G8
but yeah maybe that is necessary
actually okay they're not going for that
so oh that must have been a mouse
slip am on
that I'm guessing that's a mouse slip
there's no no take
backs
okay so
now just win more material I
guess
okay honestly I don't even know that I
want The Rook I don't want the Rook
just going to work in on these uh these
squares over
here and they're still playing without a
piece and a
rook Knight F4 Knight
H4 no checks for
white got these with my queen Knight
here Queen H
H2 it's looking like the the best way
we'll do it while there's still a
restriction on the
queen so King has to return to G2 to
cover the mate
threat I can return here and coordinate
with the Knight on the light
squares Knight on dark queen on
light coordinate
well
just under 15 minutes
remaining okay going straight to mate in
that
one okay one more
game probably won't
count well we'll got four games
in
see who's in first
okay
um okay let's go
E4 a berserk
game yeah as mentioned I don't want
to play these with and play play it as
if they're Blitz
games um
all right we'll just go in the
center play a French it's half
considering D3 King's Indian attack
setup two Pawns in the
center and
D5 E5 E5
okay just baby stepping it so shooting
for some
hippopotamus
action let's let's go with
um they're playing a bit slower I'm
going to sneak in F4 Knight
F3 oh wow okay I actually missed that
that was even a move not saying it's
good
but yeah definitely induces some
weaknesses
I don't really mind so much that these
weaknesses are created uh I haven't
committed my Bishop just yet so I could
put my Bishop on
G2 cover these squares and then some
perfectly healthy diagonal but I'd still
like to leave
that um option open where exactly to go
with this guy so um when I see this move
I'm thinking that
I maybe don't even want a castle
kingside um I could just go here as
well see if this takes their definitely
prepared it
seems to just exchange go for the
exchange
sacrifice
so we'll just rule that out Al together
H3 H4
G4
okay Connect
Four maybe connect
five getting a little
fancy totally unnecessary I
feel okay I'm I'm
assuming there may be gearing up for
that one let's put this guy here cover
some weaknesses some holes in my
position
still staying flexible with my Pawn
okay so I could go okay on this there is
a
check do I just support my
Center
push this is a move as well push takes I
think I would take with the
pawn
I'm pretty quick to get on the open
file yeah let's get the space computer
would probably play this
move loves the space let's play like a
computer yeah no piece
recapture and it is an idea to still
like in an earlier game play against the
backward
Pawn all right so my first thought is is
not to block with the queen just king
move and looking forward to a
pin I don't know how vulnerable my king
is really going to be on F2 there's no
development for
black I have space a lead in development
threatening to win my next move and
there's this hole over
here instead of Knight C3 now that this
structure is in there I'm thinking about
this maneuver and some clamp with the a
pawn pawn on A5 Knight on
C4 is looking very appealing now how
might the structure change on the king
side this there's that this there's that
I could always keep it
closed um don't really not anticipating
any way to disrupt this
structure
um what's squares does black even have
available let me start with this
guy I'm not concerned about a check on
this diagonal I always have a counter
punch okay now I am a little bit
concerned about Knight E4 I do actually
I do have to worry a little bit about
something a sacrifice on this square
there's two minor pieces
here okay so given that that might be a
move
I think I like this
move covers Knight E4 bishop and Knight
and opens up my queen to
defend I still have this check in
hand
okay
this move and
C4
H let's see what is
best
h I mean putting the Rook on the open
file seems
Supernatural castles though what's my
followup like what's my what's my second
move if I go here this might be a move I
end up in a
pin Knight C2 I guess Knight
C2 I guess Knight C2 they don't play I
think they maybe have to try C4 here I'm
really close to having a a wonderful
clamp on the queen side get these moves
in it's going to be
really tough for team
black could easily run out of
Moves Like okay so I'm really close to
getting this in so here's the other
here's a detail if they try a knight
exchange I duck it
Knight
E3 and then I give the Knight a kick and
return to C4 ideally I'd like to still
play with four minor pieces given that I
have
space Pawn on
D5 might it try to maneuver over
here maybe okay get that one in
now well there's extra defense over this
Square
my eyes is continually on the the
forward moves for
black this guy
especially this Square okay so if I go
here Knight
here here Knight
here
um would you really do
that I don't know that it's getting
black anywhere I could go here and I'm
threatening to win the KN I think they
have to go
back it's probably in the computer's
eyes just a winning position or I I
could go here straight
away all right I think I go in for this
now
yeah and here's the detail once once B5
is in I have this idea to take and then
play Knight
A5 of course I am exchanging minor
pieces with this sequence but in a way
I'm extending the scope of this bishop
if I have my knight
on
A5 getting into this
Square it's probably slower a
approaches I'm going to go for this one
though they're under 2 minutes the
Knight right here still a bit of a
clumsy
piece this is a half open B file The
Rook doesn't function until the Knight
goes somewhere else and I'm not sure
where that somewhere else
is so now they have to constantly look
out for a knight drop on
C6 you probably can't work around the
Knight
so I'm expecting that if I go in here
they have to take but then they have to
deal with a p
Pawn
okay I'm going to go one step I
think yeah let's go one expecting that
move yes okay there is a check
here
put the bishop here a little
faster Pawn controls the Knight Bishop
restricts the queen to a certain
extent I think running in here straight
away there might be a tactic on
D5 not entirely sure on that one okay
taking with the pawn so
now
there's a another piece that could
coordinate with my pawn bishop and
Knight that may have been a mouse
slip couple checks for my
night well this is the move that's
crying out to
me Queen can't go too far I think they
have to go
into pin maybe or
here it's not a not a fun position for
black
okay now there's that
one also just activate the other Rook
feel like there should be some knockout
here Knight's going to reroute to this
Square
soon maybe I jump in
now
maybe
get a yeah also there's maybe this still
available let's let's hop in and how to
recap I think I'm going to capture with
the
pawn get a pass Pawn this Square opens
up for my
pieces their light squares become super
weak down to 30 seconds let's take with
the
pawn so this one is threatened winning
the night next okay let's keep the foot
on the gas somewhat
uh this could be this could be a thing
how about the queen right in the
center Queen here if the Knight moves
maybe or maybe before I even do that I
get my last piece
involved right
here Rook B8 then there's Queen C4
double attack there might even be Knight
takes here straight
away
okay Bishop D5 as well could be a
move but let's go with Queen here
threatening m one
seconds go away there is this move
wow
okay
let's just go for the queen
trade Knights are on their back foot
rooks are disconnected I got the past
Pawn take with the Rook on this
guy and just
push yeah down on
time I think that was a a well played
game there in the
end uh um and they had a slower approach
there the small Pawn center right out of
the gates
but okay in the end got four games
in throw a GG's
all all right that's going to do it for
this video uh Feel Free as usual to
leave any feedback in the comments
section below hope you enjoyed it and
maybe took a thing or two away that's
all for now take care bye